shin fein are looking on the brink of
winning the local elections in northern
ireland if they manage to do that
they'll be looking for a border
referendum i put that to the government
this morning and they said that's up to
us we'll decide whether there's a
referendum or not even though the people
of northern ireland democratically voted
to have a border referendum with the
rest of ireland uniting the two
countries do you think that labour would
also say totally up to the british
government whether or not that goes
ahead or do you think they would
acquiesce
well let's see what happens in the
elections tomorrow um i want northern
ireland to stay part of the united
kingdom we do though need to to to
ensure that the brexit that we have
works for the people of northern ireland
that we can get goods and services uh
between
great britain and northern ireland and
there's that free flow of goods so much
more is needed i think to persuade the
people of northern ireland the the
brexit deal that the government secured
and said was a good deal for northern
ireland actually works for the people of
northern ireland if we had a labor
government that would be my focus to
ensure that not just that we get brexit
done that we make brexit work for the
whole of the united kingdom including
for people in northern ireland i
understand that but what about if the
people of northern ireland decide that
actually they don't want to be part of
the union anymore would a
labour government stand in the way
well i i don't think that
the results on thursday
tell you anything about what people want
in terms of their future relationship
with
the united kingdom or indeed with
the republic of ireland
of course it is a decision for the
british government whether there are a
referenda of these sort whether it's in
northern ireland or in scotland but
let's see what happens in the results
not just in northern ireland but in the
whole of the united kingdom uh yesterday
where people are voting on a huge range
of issues and perhaps most of all
northern ireland
let's stay focused on what we're asking
you about let's stay focused on what
we're asking you about i'm asking
whether if shin fein won the election
and labour was in power they would stand
in the way of a border referendum which
is what the people of northern ireland
would have voted that they wanted
well what i'm saying is that people in
northern ireland tomorrow are voting on
a whole range of uh issues uh not least
on the cost of living crisis which is
affecting people right up uh and down
our country including in northern
ireland so i don't think you can make uh
an implication by how people vote what
they want to see in terms of their
future relationship with the whole of
the united kingdom let's see what
happens in the results tomorrow but we
do need to do much more to help people
in northern ireland to ensure that
brexit works for northern ireland and
indeed for the rest of the united
kingdom but also that those crucial
issues because people in northern
ireland are like everybody seeing higher
prices in the shops
higher prices for filling up the car
with petrol and perhaps most of all at
the moment those higher gas and
electricity
bills and that's why labour are calling
for an emergency budget for the whole of
the united kingdom to have a windfall
tax on the huge profits that are being
made by north sea oil and gas companies
and use that money to take up to 600
pounds of people's bills immediate
action now to help with the cost of
living crisis sure and we saw yesterday
the huge profits being made by bp um
almost five billion pounds in just three
months
i'm just going to try once more i'll get
on to that in a second if i made
miseries i'm going to try once more sinn
fein want a border referendum if the
people of northern ireland vote for shin
fein ergo they want to board a
referendum would the labour party
whether they're imperil not would you
support what the people of northern
ireland want to achieve with their
country
well look let's see what happens in
those election results yes tomorrow but
people vote in elections on a whole
range of issues and not just
constitutional issues but i think most
pressing of all on the cost of living
crisis okay windfall tax we heard this
from george eustis representing the
government this morning have a quick
list
we've already got a higher rate of tax
for those companies in north sea oil
it's all ready and they pay enough tax
well it's a corporation tax it's already
10 percent higher um we judge that's the
right thing at the moment we don't want
to deter investment um in the north sea
uh they're a big employer um bp um for
instance already saying it wouldn't
deter them but they would they would
continue to invest even if there was a
windfall tax george osborne did it so
why would you not do it do you feel
they're paying off taxes i'm sure you
know richie sunak will look at these
things and keep all of these things
under review
so there you go government think that
the oil companies pay enough tax for now
i think that george eustis is totally
wrong on this and i think the government
are totally wrong on this the north sea
oil and gas companies at the moment are
making record profits because of the
huge increase in gas and oil prices it
is right that we ask them to pay a bit
more into the system to help people who
are struggling with their gas
electricity bills at the moment who are
paying the price for those record high
oil and gas prices and a windfall tax
could be used to take up to 600 pounds
of people's gas and electricity bills
and the chancellor last week said it
would be silly to help families now
i think that is deeply insulting to
people because people are struggling now
labour has set out its plans for a
windfall tax to spike the hike in
national insurance to give people relief
with the cost of living crisis right now
the government need to urgently come
back with their plans because it is not
good enough to sit on the sidelines and
say
that you know people as george eustis
has said this morning oh if people just
buy own brand products they'll be um
they'll be okay people are not okay
people are struggling with those higher
prices and it is incumbent on government
to act not to sit on the sidelines and
george eustis says it will deter
investment you know even the chief
executive of bp
says that a windfall tax would not in
fact affect one single investment
project so what is it that stopped the
government from acting what's stopping
the government i know you did okay but
he didn't answer you he didn't the
chancellor said i can only do my best if
you like when i'm talking to you as
reeves
well i spoke to him yesterday and i'm
seeing him later today so you know keira
and i speak uh regularly we're
absolutely united and focusing on the
cost of living crisis to help
commissioners this is what i want to ask
you how many people
were at that event in durham um whether
30
i don't know how many people were there
but i do know that durham police have
looked at it
the durham police have looked at it and
said that there is no case to answer so
it is a million miles apart from the
industrial scale law breaking that we
saw at number 10 downing street with
party after party and the metropolitan
police have issued more than 50 fines to
downstream including to the prime
minister let's leave that to one side
that's the conversation i have for the
government but i want to ask you miss
reeves if i may
do if there were because he's been on
the telly this morning and he hasn't
denied your leader that 30 at least 30
people were at this event certainly they
spent something like 200 quid on the
foods that's an awful lot of curry one
would suggest um
if there were 30 people there are you
confident that every single one of those
people that was there should have been
there and we're working
well it was just a few days before last
year's local elections and i know from
running my own campaigns in leeds where
i'm an mp that we have a number of
people in the office on election day uh
on the phones out on the doorsteps
and people stopped for to have some food
and then they carried on at working the
police though have looked at this and
said that there is no case to answer so
it is so different from the industrial
scale law breaking that we saw at number
10 downing street where the police have
investigated and they have issued fines
and also very different from the prime
minister who lied lied and lied again
and tried to cover up his lies uh both
to uh to to parliament and to the public
and that is why these two incidents are
so so different yeah although you know
the deputy leader was there and there
were a few porcupies going on we had to
press and press and press until we found
out that she was there i mean you're
going to tell me that wasn't a lie that
was just a mistake what's the difference
well look i think that when this was
first reported to durham police last
year uh the feeling was that
that no rules were broken and that's
what durham police said and so you know
we just moved on and now the tories are
raking this up again because they're
trying to distract from their own law
breaking and and criminality at downing
street understand why they're doing that
because they want to sling mud and hope
that some of it sticks on others but the
metropolitan police have been very clear
they've issued already more than 50
fines to the very people who were
supposed to be making the laws to keep
us all safe and the prime minister does
seem to think that it's one rule for
everybody else and another for him and
those close to him yeah but you've got
to accept that if the labour party is
saying that the deputy leader wasn't at
this event and then it transpires some
months later that actually she was at
this event because of investigative
journalism that was found out it also
transpires that more than 200 pounds was
spent on food and your leader says that
quite possibly more than 30 people
were there
you know what sort of oh and there was
also some online quiz type thing that
was going on and none of that was
immediately obvious this time last year
isn't it only fair that durham police
should look at this again
well i'm not going to make operational
decisions for the police or suggest what
they should or should do
they've already looked at it and they've
said that there's no case to answer that
is uh their verdict on uh the uh the the
events that were reported to them look i
understand that the tory mps want to uh
distract and deflect from their own rule
breaking and and law breaking but it's
the prime minister who has been fined
it's the prime minister's office that
have been fined now more than 50 times
and uh probably more to come and they
were supposed to be making the rules and
people feel rightly so very angry that
they made huge sacrifices often not at
the birth of a new baby not the sides of
loved ones when they were
dying not being able to visit relatives
in hospital people made huge sacrifices
to keep others safe and yet we now know
because of the fines issued by the
metropolitan police that number 10
downing streets who were responsible for
making the laws were not even obeying
them themselves